jean-marie girier qui était le directeur
de campagne de emmanuel macron à la
femme a dit alexandre qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est-ce que tu souhaiterais faire je
pense que tu as une compétence et du
pourrait nous aider dans l'aventuré
présidentielle et c'est normal que vous
claquez pas la portée des gens qui n'ont
pas dormi plus de trois heures pendant
une durée de quatre mois cinq mois ont
pas vu leurs familles et qui en plus ont
été bons dans ce qu'ils faisaient alors
je le dis sans modestie mais un certain
nombre de personnes qui étaient présents
pendant la campagne présidentielle avec
des compétences alors moi c'était
l'organisation et la logistique et la
sécurité
on va pas le nier parce que j'ai connu
ça j'ai fait ça pendant neuf ans
d'autres été bon sur la culture mais ils
ont été recrutés comme chargée de
mission culture d'autres été bon sur la
presse eh bien ils ont été recrutés
comme attaché de presse et c'est normal
c'est le fonctionnement normal et celles
issues normales d'une campagne
présidentielle crois que madame jourdain
ne vous demandez pas si c'était normal
ou pas mais
mais comment vous avez été recruté eh
ben je vais répondre précisément j'ai on
m'a indiqué que les fonctions qu'on
ciblait pour moi et des sels qui était
fixé à la chefferie de cabinet parce
qu'elle correspondait à mes compétences
c'est à dire une mission d'organisation
générale de coordination générale de
terrain ce que j'aime et donc j'ai été
ensuite appelée par le service des
ressources humaines de la présidence de
la république auquel j'ai eu un
entretien qui m'a demandé ce que je
faisais avant quel était mon salaire
quelles étaient mes compétences je
l'aurais apporter mes diplômes je leur
ai porté mais attestation ça c'est pas
fait comme ça j'ai eu un entretien avec
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la république patrick strzoda qui est le
patron de la maison même si aujourd'hui
un directeur général des services qui a
été nommé mais c'est lui qui recrute le
personnel et on m'a annoncé que j'étais
recrutés sous le statut de chargés de
mission qui est un statut même titre que
vous avez été secrétaire général de
l'elysée le cheval dont vous connaissez
ça par coeur il ya des chargés de
mission et vous avez des conseillers et
ensuite vous avez d'autres personnes qui
ont occupé une place à part le
secrétaire général le directeur de
cabinet et éventuellement de conseils de
conseiller spécial
mais le statut c'est très important de
le rappeler le statut fixe votre salaire
à partir de man vous avez un statut de
chargé de mission pouvait être dans
d'autres fonctions mais mon statut
s'était chargé mission c'est-à-dire le
niveau le plus bas de ce qu'on peut
trouver au cabinet du président de la
république
donc on doit être une dizaine et vous
avez un salaire qui est fixé et j'ai été
fixé à la chefferie de cabinet en
attendant l'arrivée d'un chef de cabinet
parce qu'on n'en a pas eu pendant
dizaine de jours de mémoire donc on a
commencé à découvrir cette maison aller
au contact du personnel les chefs de
service essayer de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne et il y avait un premier
déplacement au mali il a fallu tout
faire dans la langue que vous découvrez
ces nouveaux surtout pour une équipe
comme celle d emmanuel macron c'était
nouveau d'arrimer même s'il avait déjà
une expérience de cette maison mais
pendant dix jours
j'étais tout seul la chefferie de
cabinet jean marie j'irai n'étant plus
là françois-xavier lauch est arrivé et
il ya eu un entretien avec françois
xavier qui m'a demandé un peu de douche
venez qu'est ce que j'avais fait avant
qu est-ce qu de quoi j'étais capable et
il m'a dit ok très bien donc j'étais
pris comme chargé de mission auprès du
chef de cabinet et ensuite les fonctions
ont pu évoluer
j'ai conservé mon statut de chargés de
mission et au sein de la chefferie de
cabinet nous étions 4
avec un chef de cabinet un chef de
cabinet adjoint ou un chef adjoint de
cabinet ces deux nominations des
nominations sont des titres parce qu'ils
impliquent une nomination au journal
officiel et ensuite nous étions deux
chargés de mission dans des fonctions
d'adjoint au chef de cabinet ça a été
précisé par patrick strzoda devant la
commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale il me semble il ya trois
choses il ya le statut qui détermine
votre salaire votre position sociale si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi au sein du
cabinet votre fonction c'est ce que vous
faites au quotidien et le titre le titre
vous pouvez vous en prévaloir c'est
celui de chef adjoint de cabinet ou de
chef de cabinet adjoint dès lors que
vous êtes nommé au journal officiel
voilà pour être très précis avec vous
les réponses que je peux vous apporter
madame jourdain oui alors je vais encore
vous vous demander quelques précisions
car en réalité vous êtes précis mais pas
sur la question qui était qui vous a
recruté que vous avez commencé à parler
de jean-marie girier vous l'avez re cité
après ensuite vous avez dit on m'a
demandé qui est c'est-à-dire
concrètement comment s'est passée la
mise en contact on comprend bien que
monsieur strzoda tu es votre supérieur
hiérarchique
en réalité il est normal que ce soit lui
qui vous recrutent mais comment le
contact s'est fait en réalité
alors pour être très précis
jean marie cherrier a fait l'interface
vous êtes dans une phase de transition
quand vous arrivez à la présidence de la
république nouvellement élu ce n'est pas
quelque chose de normal et vous avez un
certain nombre de personnes qui prépare
la transition qui vont y rester et
d'autres qui s'en vont qui vont dans
d'autres fonctions et donc il ya eu un
moment
moi même je ne sais pas qui a décidé de
quoi pour moi on m'a fléché quand je dis
on je ne sais pas si c'est sûrement le
président de la république avec alexis
kohler avec patrick strzoda qui étaient
nouvellement nommé qui n'est pas qui n'a
pas fait la campagne patrick strzoda il
a été recruté sur ses compétences sur
son expérience professionnelle et son
expérience en cabinet au plus haut
sommet de l'état et donc quand ils
arrivent patrick strzoda il connaît pas
alexandre benalla donc il doit monter
une équipe et il est conseillé par
l'ancienne équipe en l'occurrence jean
marie girier et peut-être alexis kohler
qui est là et il ya des discussions qui
se font et ils n'ont pas passé je pense
30 minutes sur moi il
du balai ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui étaient dans des fonctions
on va dire importance pendant la
campagne et à qui ils ont fléchi d'un
certain nombre de fonctions certains sur
le fond d'autres sur la forme
et voilà comment j'ai été recruté
ensuite j'ai été sollicité un entretien
avec patrick strzoda je me dis que mon
profil était bon et que c'était bien
d'avoir un profil différent un peu à la
chefferie de cabinet que ce qui se fait
habituellement
voilà merci de cette ressource madame
jourdain dernière question en ce qui me
concerne
quelle est votre activité
professionnelle actuelle le pôle emploi
bien